boulet care podcast
roulette cat show special guest
kid inc is here ladies and gentlemen
what's happening what's up buddy
man let me turn my phones off something
yeah you got to turn the phones off bro
buzzing in here
uh first of all man uh i feel like i
ain't seen you since the panda well did
i see her
i haven't seen you since the pandemic
you no
did we see each other i think i saw you
on facetime
yeah i think that's probably what it was
you know that's seeing people yeah i
think uh
yeah it's been a crazy year man um how
have you like
uh you know how has the pandemic kind of
like
has it affected what you do or what
maybe what some things you had planned
like how did it
kind of affect life for you bro um i
mean it affected me like everybody else
as far as
obviously the slowdown of traveling and
work i mean
i you know i'm saying work traveling all
day so
i had like two
overseas tours i had like an asia tour i
had an australia tour i had a college
run
as soon as the pandemic hit all i got
yeah i know yeah
you do your runs in like the middle east
you go to dubai
everything was was ready to go for that
run and uh
you know what i'm saying i actually was
in dubai february
and i had heard about everything that
was going on i was as i was out there
and how i was like
these possible lockdowns and then i made
it home just in time
wow like literally i think couple days
after i made it home which
actually had made it home my daughter
was born
the day i made it home on valentine's
day and then
the whole thing shut down so i had to
handle all that like so the day you got
because was your wife with you in dubai
because usually she travels with you she
didn't go with you
because she was pregnant and she wasn't
close to delivering so you know
you got back the day she gave birth yeah
do you
can you imagine if you would have gotten
the next day yeah i was in the
in the airport [ __ ] i gotta get back
fast hey hold on
just don't don't like yeah no literally
in the airport hold on i'm gonna be in a
minute just get a couple hours just just
chill
yeah i'm gonna lay over please damn
that's crazy
that's baby number two baby number two
wow that was different because i had to
like
really handle all that you know i'm
saying dolo with the crib
everything was kind of shut down we
weren't able to go to the hospital
and then you're being like extra careful
because you got to basically oh i was
super
but i guess that was easy too because
having a new baby you're already super
careful
so i was already stocked up on
everything like hand sanitizers and this
and that
everything that people was panicking
over for a minute i was a little stocked
up early
because i already had to worry about i
was the baby i was the same way
as soon as uh we had a shout out doc
winter he had like some homie who worked
for i don't know some government agency
and was like yo this shit's really about
to get shut down i think it was about a
week before it happened
and i went to ralph's and just i was
that [ __ ] who had like
cases of rom i still in my garage still
have like
a whole entire supply of [ __ ] that is
like just sitting there yeah it's a
bunch of y'all man cause y'all
y'all went to the store and cleaned it
out and then
when i went to the store it was dry i
just i just ran out of toilet paper
right i bought toilet paper in a year
yesterday i went down to the closet to
see like oh i got to go get get the new
i was like oh wait we finally out
why was everybody so worried about
toilet paper because ass paper is like
essential bruh imagine that was the most
essential thing
like every time you take a [ __ ] you got
to take a shower then
if you if you don't have the toilet
paper like that yeah i'm like that too
listen if it's a rough if it's a rock if
it's one of those you gotta jump in the
shower
you know obviously but you know shout
out to my wife you know i'm like listen
if we're gonna have sex i'm gonna take a
shower anyway so you don't have to worry
about it nonetheless
um damn so you're raising an infant
during covid your wife you were just
telling me your wife just opened a new
business during covid
yeah so you was just dealing with a lot
of [ __ ] huh it was a lot going on but i
think you know
i set myself up luckily like i was
already working on the
gym so like everybody who was like dang
the gym clothes yeah i've seen you in
the garage
i was in the garage getting getting
crazy and then uh
you know what i'm saying i got the
studio at the house so that was like
mandatory of just you know what i'm
saying i'm at the crib you know i'm
saying
it's work i ain't got nowhere else to go
i ain't traveling nothing so it was
easier to kind of i think
dial in and just be creative and just
have fun because it really wasn't
nothing else to
think about or worry about like that so
a lot of this album did you record it at
home
all of it all of it according to career
all of it i recorded the crib
mixed with the crib mastered it the crib
everything was
so you kind of rusted this whole joint
yeah man i i
besides you you've worked with the
producer yeah because what it is
man i i definitely i
put it and it took a little longer than
i wanted just because
of course i was telling you earlier it
started off as like this type of idea it
was only going to do seven records
i love these seven records so much and i
was like man i feel like i need like
three more and then i need and then it
started to grow into this big turn into
an album and it turned into a full album
that's why even before
it was like two songs that we had
dropped because it wasn't really a
thought process of doing that album
until
we dropped those two songs and then
seeing how meanism were working together
and how
easy it was because i could have put
together a project with a bunch of
different producers i gave you all kind
of beasts i still got so many different
records but
the business still you know what i'm
saying takes time and clearing people
and
it's much easier to just work with one
guy we got an agreement
and get it done especially when you're
not working with the big label who
you know i'm saying maybe a lot of those
people are already cleared through your
label or it's just a easier system where
you know what i'm saying i'm independent
and we got to handle a lot of
clearing and making sure these people
you're selling points and publishing and
keeping track of all that stuff and it
was like
ism is the homie he's been the homie
we've already had records together and
he's nice and he's a goat low-key and uh
so you know what i'm saying we just it
was somebody i felt like i could work
with and get so many different type of
records done
compared to you know i'm saying if i
worked with some other producer maybe it
would just all
sound to the same to where this still
sounds cohesive but it's not like
boxed in tonight so the uh when you
first went independent you came on me
and head showing and
like we did an interview announced it
and you know made a big deal of it
um you've been independent for a while
now um
what are the i mean you started off
independent this is how you came into
the game
yeah you know what i'm saying by the way
is up and away gold now
yeah i think so i know records off of it
are gold or
definitely records are you know i don't
i gotta i i stop it's gotta be close
looking at all the numbers but
i just waiting and people be giving me
plaques like yo this one gold then it
it feels great when the the indy records
go go because right
like plus that's more money in the bank
you know what i mean more money in the
bank and
it just you know i'm saying it makes me
feel a little bit more like
you know i'm saying even now with just
records like i did all this dolo some of
them
in the closet like you know right before
it was any bread and those records got
plaques now they definitely still mean a
little bit more sometimes in those
other records that i kind of knew were
going to go mm-hmm i don't know that's
going to go it's going to be
one no but like coming back to
being independent and and being back in
that space for a while now like
what are the things that you've kind of
like had to adjust
to that you weren't used to with being
with rca for so long because you had a
very long run with rca
oh adjusting i mean
i guess you know because it's everything
is more hands-on like like i said
clearances and just certain things as
far as
the business are probably a little bit
more but i'm not all you know i'm saying
luckily i got will
to you know i'm saying help me with the
business side of things well i still
have to do the creative side but
i mean of course relationships
uh might be a little bit different you
know for me
going independent i tell you you know
the
i don't get a independent rate so
everything that's like was already what
it was or features or production costs a
lot of that stuff is still
the same as when kid ink was with rca so
you gotta think that's
still just coming out of my bags you
know what i'm saying i guess you know
those are certain things you gotta
probably adjust to more than you know
i'm saying when you're a little bit more
free with
doing certain things or samples and
you know just keeping it a little bit
more in-house so you don't have to worry
about all these
other stresses that you were able to let
somebody else worry about right right
because this is
a whole team all the variables you now
got to deal with as opposed to keeping
it kind of like like you said like hey
when we're working with one producer
that means we've got to do a one guy to
get these records cleared
yeah opposed to like getting you know
i'm saying
stuff back and you'd be here just the
business come back and be like dang why
y'all got to make this so difficult or
like
what i'm saying i'm just i'm rocking
like we're doing independent let's just
put something out let's just
work everybody wants to yeah not even
like we'll figure it out and i'm gonna
make sure everybody's taken care of but
not
most importantly you know i'm saying
make sure you get your bag up front but
i think it when it comes down to all
that extra
points in publishing stuff that i don't
my brain don't get all the way into like
that i start getting confused like man
now it's been a month since we've been
talking about all this right i don't
even want to do this record no more like
i wanted to put this out in this time
frame right now and i've had that happen
where
i didn't get a record out when i wanted
to put it out because the business took
so long and then it's like bro i just
this was a summer record nice november
and you just want me to feel like
i got the same energy i'm gonna get the
same response from this so
again working with ism it was like all
right i could lock these records and
i could tell him this is my beat like i
want to lock this in
and i don't have to worry about two
weeks later or a month later he told me
like yo
i sold yo i sold that beat i gave it to
someone the one that you had
like i gave it someone else hopped on it
it's crazy
that happens to me four times a year
nah cause you know producers just be
sending out packs and then
and records that i felt like oh this is
my single and then unfortunately and
then they'll be like well look this
other guy's got it and you know it's a
major label it's a bigger bag
right and then i'm of course i want to
tell you like nine but i'm not going to
tell my homie
like especially somebody rock would like
don't go get the bag and make
you know it's definitely a trade now i'm
gonna let you go get this bag bro so
take care of me the next go round take
care of me these packs when you get hot
don't don't forget
right right right but you know it is
what it is
so you had like a pretty wild journey as
far as like your come
up you came up with like a just a crazy
cult following fan base
um mixtapes your first independent album
and then when you signed you caught one
with show me
that was like [ __ ] how many streams
is that thing how many times platinum is
that record i mean
i don't know it definitely went on one
of chris brown's like
records and i was like oh breaking
records for chris
and but it wasn't let's let's be real
though it wasn't
as if i got signed though and then like
show me came out no no no you were
putting out other records like we did we
did
try like the meek mill right right the
the badass record
and uh i had a couple other singles and
i think what was the one lifted produce
did
uh [ __ ] i had like a screwed up like
hook
the uh bossing up bossing up yeah we got
the boston up record then i mean right
through ferg
and and french from the remix and then
we had some i had some records that were
going
you had records still for the more so
for the core fans but i felt like
definitely when the show me hit it was
like show me was like
over right so then like you you kind of
go on this run where you have
all of these records that are kind of in
similar vein to show me
not necessarily the same but like you
know rmb hooks
100 bpm type joints you know what i'm
saying
very successful huge tours you're all
the chris brown story i mean all these
tours
um do you feel like that that
kind of started to eat away at your like
core following
or like the ability for new fans to come
in and tap in with like
what some of your earlier fans fell in
love with because i feel like a lot of
fans kind of
the newer fans that were coming in yeah
started to kind of just see you as like
the radio guy
definitely it was definitely like i had
two separate
fans especially when you go to the shows
and i would have to like
please the core fans and the new fans at
the same time and you could see the
difference in the energies or whatever
but
i think you know
at the time when show me came out i
loved the record
but it wasn't in my head that it was
like all right we're gonna keep busting
these down
more so than people were asking for me
to bust those down like
the dj's was telling me like yeah we
love this and this
you know what i'm saying make sure you
i'm saying always you know and it felt
like something that was simple too and
everybody was telling me oh you sound
great doing it you sound comfortable
doing this and it was like all right
cool
you know what i'm saying i'll rock with
it as you know much as the hits come
through like i'm not gonna run away from
a hit record
but uh i definitely wasn't looking
forward to it being like
the not necessarily i'm gonna take
credit for
you know what i'm saying having a sound
but when people like that's the kidding
sound
i don't want them to be like that's the
only sound you can do kidding can do for
the new fans because i know it's fans
that
know what it is because like time of
your life which was kind of the first
record that
you had any radio success with was
i think like 60 some odd bpms it was
super melodic and it was just you
and those to me when i talked to certain
people like those are kidding records
like
for a nice group especially people who
really know me or people who've been
rocking like
when i put on something like that they
go that reminds me of a kid ink record
or the up and away vibes it's like
that's a kidding record and
that's the album that a lot of people
familiarized with me before
show me they're like this is the sound
that he had or the type of music he was
creating
and then you know when show me came out
not only did was it it was a whole new
way to even listen to music
at one point too like you know what i'm
saying the people who were
listening to those other records
sometimes still go to those old websites
and stuff to listen to that stuff
because it's not even available nowhere
yeah you gotta go down here
yeah people still be going on there like
yo i've had somebody ask me like
you should put something out on that
piff and i was like so you
just so you can listen to it like i'm
trying to figure that's not yeah like
you know me yeah shout out to dad piff
no shout out but i'm just saying it
would be stupid of you to put something
out solely on that pit
in 2021 in 2020 it would make any sense
right so it's like the the new fans who
only get
up to what they got on spotify and apple
and all that stuff like that
they got they can only backtrack so far
and i'd be thinking too like
it'll be people like yo you should do a
feature with this person i'd be like i
did i did like two
back then i mean they're not on the
streaming that works now but it is what
it is so
i don't know what else you know i'm
saying to
do besides that but accept it and then
just move forward and kind of just
work through it and now just showing
proving that i'm independent i got
obviously more wrong so yeah now you're
independent and you can do whatever you
want
at the same time i had this like uh
i remember when tyga was
making like before taste happened tiger
was making some wild records that were
like what are you doing bro
like i forget he was he was singing like
a r b
album right he was it was it was
horrible it just wasn't good shout out
to tiger i'm saying me
personally kev i did not i did not enjoy
that and i remember just thinking to
myself like
bro this [ __ ] is a no-brainer like tyga
just put out some tiger [ __ ] and then he
put taste out and i was like
bruh i feel you on that do you feel like
because i i heard you got some some [ __ ]
in the cup i actually heard the record
you got a rumor
shout out to rumor yeah shout out to bro
i don't know was it was nellie supposed
to get on that song
uh we we played it what happened was we
played it for nelly
uh okay i think i think because i think
when rumor played it for me he's like oh
now he's getting on this yeah we had
played it for nelly
and brought it through and then instead
we ended up doing two other records
you and ellie uh are you in rumor me
rumor and nelly did one other record
okay and me and nelly got like four
records in the canyon oh should we just
be working because that's the bros so
sometimes he'll just pull up to the crib
and then i'll just be playing that's all
i just played but i guess like
i feel like you have the like kind of
the like like if you were to do a record
like
show me or you know what whatever right
now
independently yeah you make so much
money off of that song
right because it's yours now yeah so i
mean i cuz i know you made a conscious
decision to be like yo don't send me
these beats
like don't like like this you know i'm
close with you and
your team so i'm like like i know you
made a conscious decision to be like
look like stop sending me mustard beats
stop sending me
you know these kind of records have you
thought like yo look now that i'm
independent like
if i catch one now it's like way
different have you thought of like
saying like hey [ __ ] it let's see what
happens like absolutely i think i think
what it was was when i was asking people
not to send me that stuff i just needed
it for like my mental and like creative
space
to be able to open up and not just i
just needed it for myself
so i cuz i was feeling boxed in or
insecure about
if i could take it a different direction
still whatever the case may be so
but of course i looked back and even
just listening to certain records
or just getting beats and then just
having something to it so quickly and
being like
dang this is lokia smash i definitely
told myself like
i'm not running away from nothing
especially now that you know i'm saying
summer's on the way i got a nice little
stash up for the summer and it said
i know that you know it's a vibe that
people you know i'm saying enjoy and i
know that
i love making you know i'm saying music
that make people feel good and i've been
missing the summer i'm not gonna lie so
i just
i've heard some songs that you don't
have out that are like what was the
there's a record that i know will was
trying to get kane brown on
oh yeah that's like a hit that's like
and that shit's like a year and a half
two years old that's like a smash like
these are records that you just got
just tucked off but it just needs the
perfect
the perfect person singing on that hook
and i just it got to get right you feel
me though like you got records like that
that are like
crazy yes i and and it was like
i think it was just all the time and
things like that's like a soundtrack or
like
the theme song to like you know
summerslam type [ __ ] fast and furious
you know what i'm saying exactly into
the movie
do you feel kind of like if you know you
have like okay look
like you said i got you got [ __ ] tucked
like this to me i think is like a dope
project because
it's something that's like you're
independent now so why not do a whole
project with a producer
right um but if you know like hey look i
got
this this this and this being
independent is it like a little bit
harder to be like
look guys if we're going to drop this we
got to make sure we got
all of these ducks in a row yeah because
we want to make sure it has
the best chance to be as big as it
should be
does it give you kind of cold feet to
drop something like that
now that you're independent or is it
like
more like timing like like you know what
i'm saying because you got like you said
you have some big records bro like
i feel like your biggest joints you have
you've been you've been sitting on for a
while
that's what people tell me all the time
now i i think it's definitely a
a timing thing i don't like you said
getting the ducks in a row for sure
like after i got the project done it was
more so like
all right now how we gonna line it up a
certain way and give ourselves enough
time
to be able to do boom boom boom boom
because
it was like a mission initially i was
like
i wanted to put it out at this time it
went two months over the time i wanted
to put out just trying to perfect it the
way i wanted it to sound
right and then of course i immediately
wanted to put it out
but then he stepped back and it's like
nah nah i'm not gonna do that it's not a
surprise project like
i want to give it his full potential and
you know what i'm saying
let it be seen and heard and give it
what it needs
to really you know i'm saying have some
success instead of just putting it out
and
which with records i've done before by
just wanting to put something out just
to have content out
right and then they gotta kind of get
overlooked not just be
not because the record wasn't hot
it got overlooked because it wasn't put
out in a certain manner to
you know i'm saying succeed so with this
project i definitely
at first kind of just wanted to get the
content out and let
people kind of gravitate towards it the
way they want but i still want to have
some type of impact especially
being from where i was to go independent
i don't want to lowball and be like i'm
independent now and now i'm not doing
things this big
like i'm not giving you you know i'm
saying the same type of energy because
i'm independent i'm just throwing some
music out there and seeing what happens
like
i definitely don't want it to be nothing
like that there's been this big
narrative in music over the last few
years about
um going independent ownership you know
uh kanye led a lot of that with the
publishing [ __ ] and
and obviously russ has been screaming
that [ __ ] at the top of his
head you know uh tory lanez just went
independent yeah before he shot megan in
defeats
allegedly um
but it's kind of been like you know i
think that
we kind of recognize like if you have a
cult following if you have
fans like the major label can
they can throw gasoline on a fire that's
already going on right
but the fire is already there so it's
like
talk about how important it is and like
just like coming into your own as an
independent artist again
like the second go round like how does
it feel like how are you like
like is is is being independent the way
for you now moving forward
would you ever sign another deal or like
you know what i mean like
the second go round how's it feeling uh
i couldn't say i wouldn't sign another
deal
um in general i mean i definitely want
to see
how this run goes i don't you know i
have
certain expectations for myself but i
just want you know i'm saying i
definitely want to see how it goes
and uh see how i move forward from there
i am
in a good space you know what i'm saying
with my independent situation i feel
like
especially after this project that you
know i'm saying i'll be able to
figure out what i want to do and i
expect probably to
you know i'm saying get some some calls
in and i'm gonna have to make some
decisions but
i don't know i mean if it if it makes
sense because i understand
uh if the pro so if the project i it's
not the only project i plan on putting
out by the way but if this project
you know what i'm saying gets the
response that i want it to get and
it kind of shines the light on the the
creative
and the different ways i can go and then
that
sparks an interest in you know what i'm
saying a major label or a bigger
independent label or whatever that
understands that direction and i feel
comfortable about them i understand that
and i can continue to do what i'm doing
with that backing of course because
that's how it was when i first went in
and it felt that you know what i'm
saying
confident about i can continue to do
what i want to do and it's going to
continue to get back
the only problem that had happened with
the label before was
like you're saying with me doing what i
wanted to do but then having a show me
record be
way more successful than anything i did
before compared to probably some
independent artists that had a platinum
record before they came in and then you
know what i'm saying
i had a lot of success but for them they
probably still felt like
but this record did way bigger so you
know what i'm saying we'll put more
energy into when you give us that type
of stuff
if the you know i'm saying a newer
situation is like whatever you want to
do
blase blah will give you this this this
this and that and make it work for me
then you know i'm saying i'm gonna hear
him out
but also if this project you know i'm
saying
skyrockets and the baggage you know i'm
saying crazy
just like yeah keep running this [ __ ] up
might as well keep running it up i'm not
gonna be
what i'm saying just jump into it if i
could because i understand the system so
it's not like i don't understand how to
run my own
situation like a major label or you know
what i'm saying
put it together and don't have the
relationships or you know what i'm
saying don't know how to take that back
and reinvest it the right way so you
know i know how to
like i've been doing now i know how to
put together this i know how to shoot
videos i know how to it's not you know i
know how to market that and we know how
to where to get that you're
self-sustaining
i mean yeah i think that that's like you
know what right because really if you
think of the major label [ __ ] that
really
the thing that they could do is just
give you an upfront bag that's really
all it is and that up front bag you got
to recoup at a shitty rate for the most
part
most most people is you know but you
know
they can like i said pour gasoline on
the fire but if you kind of got
the right partner or you have your [ __ ]
together on your own like
really what can they do right but mind
you anything i'd probably do like with a
major label it is going to be a one and
done so
yeah like yeah i'm not going in for no
like three to five
five years like look i got i got i got
these records they need
infrastructure let's let's see how it
works and then i'm out and i'll
make you guys a bad because i mean i
understood that's kind of what i did
for the other label with you know i'm
saying getting them such a good enough
bag
in the beginning i could you know i'm
saying just been
off the situation and continue to do
something else and they would have
succeeded equally because they
what i gave them was good enough to
clear out and you know i'm saying being
the green and
dip out so yeah they still making that
same
consistent bread off those records so
you know i'm saying that was a
successful
deal it was successful yeah i mean they
made money i thought that they
they really fumbled that last record of
yours one was sweetie and
wayne yeah that was a fumble
i don't know who to blame it on we
jumped on that record so early at real
and i was like guys this is the kidding
record this is like we gotta [ __ ] go
crazy and then
and then i just felt like the label
never backed it up
right but i mean you know what i'm
saying oh it just makes me feel good to
open the doors
be ahead of the curve and you know look
at everybody
on their bumper now yeah i mean [ __ ]
that was really was sweetie too
yeah i was like could have been
and uh what's the name didn't uh
yeah he ain't do the beat yeah yeah did
the beat and
yeah he had that paper on paper that's
the smash i don't know what happened
so but yeah again that's the thing you
know
even the record you had with tyler on
your ep a few years ago i thought could
have been [ __ ] huge which was still
that was still a big record but i feel
like with the uso record i think there
were obviously still some things that
could have been lined up and
probably situated so it wasn't maybe as
rushed out
as i probably wanted it to be out too is
everybody like i needed to wreck her out
we put this together boom boom boom but
probably could have you know what i'm
saying i don't know done something
different hey
i know you're watching the interview
right now thank you for watching we
ought to interrupt this for a special
uh announcement from our good good good
good sponsors over at odd socks
i have all socks on my feet as we speak
these are nwo socks you know i mean a
wolf pack you know somehow
shout out to um odd socks though if
you're watching this
go to oddssoxoficial.com and buy the
most comfortable socks in the world
and i truly do mean that these right
here these are the most comfortable
socks in the world
these are the basics they're just plain
[ __ ] great
you know they got all the licenses
spongebob wwe
just everything you could ever want yeah
i mean i'm just throwing socks at nico
blitz right now our producer is filming
this
but uh look go to oddssharksofficial.com
trust me they got the masks the boxers
everything you need my personal favorite
that i've been loving is they got the
naruto
and i'm not even into that [ __ ] but the
socks are fly and the street fighter
socks
crazy licenses odd socks official dot
com keyword
bootleg kev right now save 20 off at
checkout but the
the tie record you know i think that was
still a big
a big record for me i think at the time
what it was was
which is weird because yeah all the fans
want a certain
situation for me but i think at that
time
it was a time maybe when i needed to
kind of not switch it up but just maybe
throw something in different right
before that that kind of
made them miss that right that sound or
that vibe
and then come back to it instead of it
being maybe something a little too
consistent
right so people were kind of like all
right but like kind of how i went main
chick
which was wasn't my move but how many
[ __ ] came out right after show me how
they weren't able to
get to that because they were still here
so like you know it's crazy because main
chick if you would have like you said if
you had a bridge record in between those
two records
main chick probably would have been i
mean the main chick was a big record it
was still a big wreck it was a big
record but
it could have been huge it could have i
think had its own legs
and been crazy instead of feeling like a
follow-up yeah because people were still
playing show me
yeah because show me research so well at
radio that was like one of those songs
that didn't go away for like a year and
a half on the radio because it
researched so well so you dropped the
follow-up and
it's like yo i'm already playing i'm
still playing the other [ __ ] yeah and
then
people telling me that to my face was
like yeah how come how come they didn't
know that
that was something that somebody that's
not something i was just be honest these
labels don't know what to do
they were supposed to know because
that's their job so yeah
i don't know how they are you finding it
um
easier to like cause cause like i said
you came in the game with this crazy fan
base
since you've come back to being
independent you've been dropping a lot
more off
like i think was it 2019 you were
dropping it felt like once every month
you were putting a new we did like one a
week
it was a lot of songs like two months i
think you were dropping a lot of records
have you found it um easier to kind of
rehash that fan base and like re like
kind of
because i feel like you you know turning
into a superstar sometimes you
lose those core fans because they kind
of feel like ah well yeah
you know what i mean have you found it
easier to try to like
bring those guys back into the fold or
build that back up
a little bit because now i mean it's
certain fans i think that are back to
rooting for me because they feel like
i'm the underdog
and then you know i i could feel like at
the end of 2019 when i was
had this idea making this run and then
2020 happened and the energy kind of
shifted a little bit of course of course
i like have records lined up in
different things but
it's a timing thing too i remember
having certain records that i felt like
were ready to go and it was kind of like
yeah but not anymore so anyway we're
gonna have to wait until this one is you
know i'm saying give it
four or five months and then see if the
energy is back ready for it so
that definitely kind of helped i may not
help but it definitely kind of slowed
down my run but
at the same time i think gave me some
more just
creative time to get some stuff together
and figure some stuff out and
in the midst of recording this project
too i think i was able to
open up just getting back into more
sinks
because sinks i don't know if a lot of
people know like movies movies
tv shows commercials and stuff those are
big i don't know like i've always had a
niche with just writing records
that just you know what i'm saying
resonate over there with that sinking
game and
i got back into that and you know what
i'm saying i think i'm on
because like what have i done like two
i've had like two fast and furious
movies we're working on another one they
you know i'm saying people were sending
space jam
ideas and this and that and it was doing
trolls and all these different movies
was
coming out and i think i you know what
i'm saying just tap back in and just
writing for that type of game and it's
like those your records are records you
write
for like like are those like your
records ended up on that stuff or
sometimes just stuff that you write
that ends up someone else doing them or
so like
this so i've had a couple different ones
like sometimes you'll get the list
that'll tell you what they need
and then you get you know what i'm
saying to it just start writing a bunch
of different stuff and send it through
and then i've had records that like
there was a record i did
on the ism project for the album
that i lost to a movie sink because
you know i'm saying ism played it for
his people and they were like yo that
would be perfect for this movie
and i was like yeah but that's for my
album so like that was another thing
that happens where to set me back too
because i think losing that one record
which i felt like i needed and it had a
certain sound
set me back and i had to replace that
with like
i needed so if that happens does that
song then just belong to the movie
company yeah
so like they are like hey look we're
putting this in the movie it's ours if
we put it out on the soundtrack
yeah so like i sold it to them and then
they you know i'm saying through
you know i'm saying whoever they wanted
a couple different rappers on there
maybe had somebody re-sing the hook
blase blah and then you know what i'm
saying i sent it to me
i added some stuff or you should put
some ad-libs here you know what i'm
saying we still work on the record
together but once it's there it's just
there's to
do you know what i'm saying they went
for the movie right right right right
yeah i think the scene game is a part of
the game that a lot of artists don't
understand
or like understand even how to get
involved in that because you'll hear
some records you're like man this should
be great on a movie or something i don't
even think people understand that world
it's like it feels like a different
world
right because the movies the sports is
big for me like i had the uh
the dodger championship song and
the song that they played and that's a
bag a series opener
yeah so the dodgers just shoot a bag and
i'm saying some tickets maybe you know
uh but uh shout out to william shout out
to ill will
and then uh so like i get those i've had
different um saying like championship
spots video games like all that stuff is
real fun to me like
that was something that growing up i
always wanted so like i always wanted to
have a song on the radio but then
like i got a song in a video game yeah
the video game [ __ ] is like could you we
always be playing madden or 2k
yeah and it's or even like tony hawk
when i was growing up like all them
songs like you knew by heart
by heart brother songs know at all it's
songs i know from like
dave mirra that i've never yeah yeah
because it's
it's like you play the game so much
you're like oh this [ __ ] is crazy
i was walking around singing these songs
friends like what is this
did you play the new tony hawk like
remastered edition that came out
not okay so i want to i had to fight i
had to step back
from the video games for a minute you
was diving in i'm bad
once i dive in i dive in and then
especially during a pandemic
especially during the pandemic so for me
i had to step back from the video games
especially while i was doing this
project because i was i got lost in
there like what game
uh i play of course 2k
so 2k got the whole story mode so once
you get locked into that you'll be over
you're him
i'm out here living hoop dreams and then
anything fighting game like ufc is my
joint
uh you know call of duty's i play all
the regular games the ones i get locked
in on be like the batman spider-man
oh yeah spider-man rock the switch super
marios is all
fire but i had to step back for a second
all those batman arkham series games
were [ __ ] fine
fire those are like my some of my
favorite games that's the la that's when
i found out i had a problem
i think i went like a month in and i was
like yeah i've been playing everything
you get i had everything did you get the
new any of the new consoles the ps5 or
anything
ps5 uh i don't rock with xbox
yeah xbox man you know i'm not gonna lie
though ps5 ain't got no games yet just
like they did ps4 neither of them got
games yet
it's like bruh i told my son he was so
hyped to get i mean i got a bunch during
christmas but
i was like yo you realize like there's
no games yet that's what
they were ps4 last time it was like you
get call of duty 2k
spider-man yeah and it's two other games
and then you gotta wait six months we
gotta wait till this no [ __ ] games
gotta wait to the summer and like
low-key the i mean the graphics are
better
but unless you got that crazy tv
like if you just got a normal 4k tv you
barely can notice the difference
difference right you got to have like a
ill-ass
tv with this type of my boy was breaking
it down he's like look
for you to really like notice the jump
in graphics you gotta really have like a
[ __ ] three
four thousand hour tv yeah just to
notice the difference i could imagine
there's somebody who bought a ps5 once
my son's in his room on a 32-inch
[ __ ] 1080p tv like yeah the graphics
look better like they look the same
yeah same game my guy yeah it's like
pretty much the same [ __ ] thing yeah
it's it's kind of crazy um yo so you've
sold
over 15 million records through your
career
like i said i'm bad with the numbers but
that sounds yeah
that sounds good that's a lot so if i
could count like
that is that's that's man blessing do
you ever like reflect on like
that's a lot bro like some people never
go platinum in their life
yeah 15 million is is a number that
you could stop making music tomorrow and
be like man i sold 15 million records in
life you ever like think like [ __ ] like
u.s
worldwide i don't know because the thing
is too that that fifth harmony record
hopefully it'll go diamond at some point
in my life and i'll be
like i'm part of a diamond record how
many i feel like they're like
seven million worldwide how many records
are that period yeah
that's crazy it might be diamond
worldwide but it's like
that record was probably one of the big
i need to update that plaque i probably
only got the two million one
but no but like you know that's a lot
man that's a big that's a big career
i mean you know and for you to still
keep going but you ever reflect like yo
like everything i've done so far
it's it's impressive man i know
sometimes sometimes it's like probably
easy to like second-guess yourself or
doubt yourself when you ain't the
hottest artist anymore
yeah but like bro like you've had like a
crazy run so far
no i get i definitely get time to
reflect on it more now and i think back
like
yeah a nice little run especially when i
think about the years in so like
i look at other guys and how how long
they actually been in the game
and i think about like when my first
project dropped it when people actually
start paying attention like
2014 2015 like you know what i'm saying
wasn't like that long ago compared to
some people who've been in the game for
like 20 25
years i feel like i still got you know
i'm saying some grinding that i could do
i feel like i still got some time
of success especially when i see like a
lot of the old heads still just doing
big things
later in their career multiple runs
multiple runs i've seen so many people
have just multiple legendary runs
you've seen like fat joe keep coming out
yo perfect example fat joe keep coming
out gucci mane to keep coming out with
something crazy
i'm saying those are people that you
know you look up and you're like two
chains still coming out like
everybody even like someone independent
like freddie gibbs like freddie gibbs
you know what i'm saying too you see
people on the whole run right now that's
crazy right people who you see
10 years in maybe slow down or you
didn't think was getting what they
needed to get as far as respecting and
getting nominated for grammys and stuff
that makes you you
have no choice but to feel inspired and
motivated like oh i got
that time to figure stuff out not saying
i'm just sitting back but it's like
i got time to still you know what i'm
saying thrive so
have you felt the narrative i know you
you know you're you pay attention but
like
there's been memes and [ __ ] like what
happened to kid inc
like kid ink fell off yeah is that
something that
bothers you or is it something that
motivates you or do you even pay
attention to it
it's a little bit of both the reason it
bothers me is because i feel like
like we were talking about having
certain you know i'm saying things
aligned
i feel like i've had somebody say you
know when you're dropping something new
and then for me i'll be like i just
dropped something new two weeks ago
how did what made that count is new for
you or
or me taking this serious is this was a
record i wanted to put out
or this is you just think i'm just
throwing stuff out like you know so i
think
it's definitely still up to me i guess
to i guess put that energy
into certain records but you know it
it'll bother me to an extent
of i don't want nobody thinking i'm
chilling right with the crib like
you're working i'm blessed but i'm not
ever
content with just sitting at the crib
and i'm just going on vacations and we
collecting all these voices
it's like now i'm at the crib working
constantly thinking
being creative trying to figure out
what's something new i could do where
everything is going especially because
i'm somebody who doesn't really like
sit back on my old records and look at
them and think about you know i'm saying
oh this is something i need to redo
again or what if this would have done
this i'm always moving forward
so like people will come over to crib
and hear everything i got stashed and
they can't even know why you
did it but it's you know i'm saying
figuring everything out and just getting
not wanting that to happen where people
are overlooking records
is definitely you know what i'm saying
it puts me in that place like all right
i don't want to just put this out and i
know it's a smash but it seems like you
know i'm saying i got to figure out the
way to get
back in people's face or build the
momentum the right way so where
they just automatically it's back to
clicking and then they go oh that's
crazy
instead of being like just not hearing
it i think it's just consistency man
yeah i think it's like yo you dropped
this project just keep dropping bro
that with the songs and the videos and
that's some videos
i got this project done i think i had
already
you guys have been shooting hella videos
with maddie j shooting videos with my
bro maddie j
uh i had already started a another
like ep kind of project that's gonna be
with somebody else doing like a
mix of you know not really hip hop is
something just more i think a little bit
more worldly
type music and then i plan on dropping
probably up and away too this year
by the summer hopefully and uh what's up
with the
uh is the rumor a rumor joint coming
soon the rumor record is definitely
coming soon we're just getting
everything together that's definitely uh
one of those ones that was a a big
record that needs some
some clearances and it's going to take
some business time but i think
everything is
set in stone i got a couple things i
need to finish on the mixing side of
things because
i'm real hands-on with that so i got the
session at the crib probably you know
i'm saying tweak some stuff but it's
already lined up
so you know i'm saying go i just got to
hit my deadline if there's an artist
that's watching this that's on the come
up would you give them advice to stay
independent or go with a major
let's say they got a little bit of
momentum it's different for different
artists everyone's situation is
different but yeah because there's
certain artists who i'd never think
should go to a major and certain ones
who i think need to go to a major so
they can get the looks
so who do you think like like like like
talk about the type of artist you think
would need to go to a major and or
should stay independent
like an example i think like from my
perspective
if you have like a song that goes viral
but you really don't have a following
yeah like you might want to go the major
route right right because
then you they'll maximize that record
because that record might be the only
opportunity you have right let's say
like that board in the house kid right
uh-huh you had that record that went
viral yeah i haven't heard from him
since but he
signed a deal and then they put the
tiger in the remix and i think that was
probably a smart play for him
definitely a smart player if it's
somebody who's got a crazy following
right like russ or somebody or let's use
let's use like
blast citizens last like is he signed to
a major
no he's got a partnership with red with
rebel music i think that that's somebody
probably who's really dope and will
succeed
doing their independent thing but if he
was assigned to a major could he be way
more why artists
absolutely so you think or like that's
like saying if
if roddy rich didn't sign to a major or
just stayed independent do i think
you know what i'm saying yeah i think
roddy richard a major is
so you think the last that amazing
major is essentially a little
solidifying as a superstar yeah
yeah i think so because he has those
type of records that i think get
overlooked that are
way that are huge you know what i'm
saying or you know i'm saying radio
ready or just a single that
everyone will like just because it
sounds sonically just good
so last is an alien have you worked have
you got to link with him at all no i
feel like you guys were
yeah i think so i was definitely a fan
uh
early and then you know what i'm saying
i'm somebody too because it's like i'll
be a fan of people
and then once they get like their wave
going
i'll hit people up and be like congrats
to this and that and then i don't i feel
like i'd be seeming like the person who
hopped on the wave
right more so than i'm just like seeing
it like from the outside like dang i
watch you grind up i remember when i was
the only person listening to you and
then i hit you and then
you might think like dang they just
trying to hop on the way have you
reached out to blast
i don't remember if i reached out to bla
i know i follow him i feel like i might
have sent blasts to dm or something
or something because i worked i got a
record with beno
beno's crazy yeah i got a record with
beno right now and uh i remember that's
kind of where i heard blast was from
latinos
so uh but now i planned on reaching out
you know i was letting it just
that might be a vibe you in blast i
think that would be
easy because i i hear when i hear it i
hear already what i would
would do and how comfortable that would
be hey he's working man i know he works
with mozzie a lot
you know obviously him and bino got i
think they're working on us follow-up to
their tape but you know he's
going crazy right yeah no he's
definitely going crazy it's dope to see
that
for sure yeah that'd be that'd be wild
that'd be that might be like
that has to happen yeah i think that has
to happen i mean honestly i was thinking
about it like like if you're going to
come back with like one of them r b type
records it's got to be blast
yeah yeah i'm gonna have i'm gonna have
head hook that up yeah that'd be crazy
that would be fire though um well look
the album is out friday
friday thursday night midnight thursday
actually
this will come out next monday so that
i'm gonna already be out actually
i don't know when this is gonna come out
i'm gonna ask will when he wants us to
drop this because we might drop it
friday
yeah but you know it'll be out i'm out
now
i'm out uh alive 13 records
uh three already out so 10 brand new
records y'all never heard
videos coming videos coming i got a you
know what i'm saying night and day
video drop day data album and then
i wanted to stack up a bunch of videos
uh
i got a couple different promo videos
for some of the records but i kind of
want to
take that first week and see what people
are rocking with and make sure i give
them that first one first season
the metrics and be like all right this
is what they're [ __ ] with yeah like
this is what they want to see a video to
right now
and then go back to just doing a video
for everything by the way
um did you ever find out who [ __ ]
got in your house um
i don't i didn't find out who got in my
house i know what they look like
i'm not i've seen i've seen the
screenshots i just didn't know if like
anything ever came with that you ever
getting your [ __ ] back or
no they were hitting houses like in your
neighborhood right yeah they was they
had a whole little thing going on and
then you know the police came
to the crib they thought i did it like
damn nearly like it was an insurance
policy they was giving me the talk and i
i almost got hot with them in the crib
and then uh after that they had like
some
some uh i don't even know what the [ __ ]
he called
some police officers or whoever
detective
detective there we go i'm [ __ ] police
some detective i was supposed to call me
and uh give me the rundown of what was
going on and updates and then every time
i
tried to hit them up there was never no
updates like that and i wasn't trying to
really keep up with the police like that
so i just kind of let it go
these fools i got jacked they jacked my
whip i
i was at the bank someone followed me
out of the bank
i'd stopped at the ups store while i was
in the ups store this was blew out my
back window
took 15 grand of cash out of my trunk
the cops had their car and they couldn't
like the license plate was like
fuzzy but they could have figured it out
they had video of the girl who followed
me out of the bank and got in that car
yeah and i'd never heard i'm like bro
did y'all even try to get my [ __ ] back
to be honest i tried way harder than
them for that
first week like i had got to a point
where
i'm the one who got the footage because
i went i went to the gas station that i
stopped at and i had to chip off the guy
i said look give me the footage
because they had to follow me here
because i went here before i went to the
other spot where i got robbed
and i had to give i gave the cops the
footage like i got the footage
that was right that's the same thing i
did i gave cops more footage and i went
to the neighbors and
it was like pointless it was one of
those things where they were supposed to
be able to go
through some other people's cameras in
the neighborhood and being able to spot
you know what i'm saying because i saw
the car but i couldn't see no plates and
then
the way that they did it's it's a whole
run they got a whole route out the
neighborhood
through the neighborhood where they
don't have they knew what they were
doing go straight to the freeway
i lost like i lost like five chains
i think my girl lost like two chains did
you have insurance basically
um to be honest i did have
insurance but they wasn't covering that
they didn't cover it nah
they didn't cover anything oh that's
some [ __ ] yeah i had paperwork and
all that [ __ ] and
i went through you know what i'm saying
everything i needed to go through but
they wasn't covering it
learning experience man yeah i learned
from it yeah well look kid ink
appreciate you coming through
new album hey let's let's um for the
radio show introduce a record man
which one we're gonna do i don't know uh
it'll be two out
whichever one you are gonna have clean
for me
oh yeah okay yeah just need to give you
that today too
all right uh yo what's up this your boy
kit inc right here and this is my new
record red light
off the project alive you already know
what it is uh we in here baby alumni
back game one time boulet kid all right
perfect